[Musique]
ils étaient onze candidats à la
présidence du conseil départemental des
jeunes ce jeudi 25 novembre
après leur représentation respective les
collégiens présents dans l'hémicycle ont
voté pour l'élection de la nouvelle
mandature
7 et milite et elson élève au collège
privé saint vincent de saint philippe
qui est élue présidente du conseil
départemental des jeunes pour son mandat
2021 2022
ben pour moi ça tu vois était un rêve
depuis 5e je suis élu le jour où je suis
arrivé j'étais un homme je me suis dit
les personnes qui sont en bas c'est des
personnes qui ont du courage qui est moi
je serai une de ces personnes je
gagnerai j'ai vaguement cyr le jour j
stressé tu as bien fait c'est arrivé
j'ai stressé j'ai été dessiné mon
discours mais quand j'ai vu que j'étais
lui je me suis dit j'ai réussi et je
suis très bien à moi un rêve s'est
réalisé et c'est un début pour
le conseil départemental des jeunes est
essentiel puisque c'est la réunion de
demain c'est notre guitare litres
réunionnaise que l'on doit porter
puisque on pense souvent en difficulté
aux jeunes qui ont du mal à s'insérer ou
qui sont
gay qui sont face à la violence etc mais
à côté de ça on a aussi des gens qui qui
porte la réunion qui porte la france est
et qui nous porte nous donc il faut il
faut les aider il faut les accompagner
le nouveau bureau du cdj intègre deux
nouveaux vice-présidents camille val
grésy du collège en albanie de la
possession et noah gaubert du collège
saint charles de saint pierre
la présidente sortante shirel gouraya
moussala ya retrace son année de
mandature avec déjà beaucoup de
nostalgie il ya beaucoup de choses mais
notamment nos deux derniers voyages on a
pu rencontrer l'élu mon manager nommé
qui avait nui qui travaillent avec nous
et 7 cet échange culturel avec d autres
drogues avec la france hexagonale
pouvoir discuter sur nos thématiques
notamment l'inclusion qui nous concerne
beaucoup nous les territoires
ultramarins mais surtout l'ambiance
l'ambiance parce que il n'y a jamais eu
depuis le jour où j'ai été élue
présidente jusqu'à là je n'ai jamais
ressenti
cette sensation de à oui non mais il ya
la présidente il ya le bureau nous on
est que conseiller on ne peut pas porter
nos idées or que pas du tout en fait
c'était vraiment tous ensemble d'accords
on a on a des casquettes on a nos rôles
mais le cdj c'est vraiment une énorme
famille où tout le monde a son mot à
chaque année ce sont plus de 200 jeunes
élus conseillers départementaux juniors
qui visent une première expérience
politique
grâce au conseil départemental des
jeunes
[Musique]